adore merci madame la parole est à
monsieur christophe priou merci monsieur
le président en écho à mon collègue
michel piron
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre après une trop longue
bataille juridique la cour
administrative d'appel de nantes a
validé hier les arrêter environnementaux
autorisant le débat des travaux de
l'aéroport du grand ouest à notre dame
des landes après 168 décision du 6 au
total
plus rien ne s'oppose donc au lancement
du chantier
conforté par la consultation du 26 juin
dernier où 55% des électeurs ont voté
oui au transfert l'aéroport comme le
précise la cour d'appel administrative
de nantes dans son arrêt rendu hier je
la cite la ministre de l'environnement
de l'énergie et de la mer chargé des
relations internationales sur le climat
par un mémoire en défense enregistré le
19 septembre 2016 a conclu au rejet des
requêtes tout arrive
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
promis une évacuation de la zad à
l'automne mais l'automne est déjà bien
avancée quand allez vous passer de la
déclaration aux actes
les arrêtés préfectoraux relatifs au
chantier de l'aéroport sont
définitivement validé merci de respecter
la voix du peuple qui s'est clairement
exprimée en faveur du projet par
référendum en juin 2016 sur proposition
de monsieur le président de la
république
que répondez vous à ceux qui entendent
ne pas respecter la procédure
démocratique et les décisions de justice
le droit ne peut pas être plus longtemps
bafouée la crédibilité des pouvoirs
publics étant déjà largement entamé
aujourd'hui il n'existe il n'existe donc
plus de procédure suspensive
confirmez-vous le démarrage des travaux
confirmez-vous que madame la ministre de
l'environnement va donner les
instructions nécessaires à la direction
générale de l'aviation civile pour
qu'elle informe le concessionnaire dti
site des décisions du gouvernement
nous les attendons maintenant monsieur
le premier ministre un calendrier précis
merci d'en informer ici et maintenant
la représentation nationale merci
monsieur prix où la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre manuel
valls
je le député christophe priou moi je
suis le premier ministre je ne suis pas
comme vous un élu de ce territoire et je
ne suis pas un élu du territoire qui est
porté depuis longtemps ce projet et je
sais vous les parlementaires les
présidents de région successifs
les élus de nantes et de l'agglomération
ont porté ce projet avec les forces
économiques considérant ce que je crois
aussi que ce projet est utile pour le
département pour la région et pour le
grand ouest
c'est un débat qui vient de loin depuis
des années il a franchi l'ensemble des
étapes les étapes administratives gelé
rappelez vous venez de le redire et
c'est ainsi
ainsi je sais pas si vous vous rendez
compte un avis uniquement de béotiens du
spectacle que vous donnez je répond
précisément à une question du député
priou qui a posé des questions précises
avec le ton et le respect qui le
caractérise sur ces sujets comme sur les
autres
j'y réponds simplement oui tous les
étapes administratives ont été franchis
une consultation locale a été même
organiser les élus locaux d'ailleurs
s'interrogeaient sur cette consultation
locale annoncée par le président de la
république elle à donner au projet une
force supplémentaire par la
participation des électeurs de loire
atlantique et par le résultat très clair
en faveur du projet et en toute
connaissance de cause parce que chacun
connaissait le fond du sujet alors il
faut respecter l'état de droit
les décisions la justice administrative
la voix du peuple qui a parlé et donc et
nous le savons pour que ce projet se
réalise et pour que la dlp ne tombe pas
chacun comprend ce que je veux dire
il faut engager en effet les travaux et
lappartient à l'état de faire respecter
cette décision
et croyez encore une fois en notre
volonté en et détermination de faire
respecter ces choses là je ne savais pas
qu à l'assemblée nationale il fallait
vous indiquez le début des travaux ou là
invention des forces de l'ordre vous
permettrez encore dans un état droit et
avec l'idée que je me fais de l'autorité
de garder ça pour nous merci monsieur
jacob vient